If you have even a little understanding of technicalities, then it has been
my experience that
if someone is taking positional trade
in options, then he is doubling the capital in 5 days and
if he is doing intraday, then he is earning 10 taka every day.
Sir, everyone does this, everyone gets it,
but not everyone has the guts to do it?
I am a retail trader.  I
meet a lot of traders.  The concept you just told is
not so easy in practical.
How I don't.
So sir, how do I do that?  Meaning, if I want to
learn any setup, I want to learn something that
this is the method, I should follow it from here.   I have to
start from A and
go to Z.  So how do I go?  You should
remove ITM, OTM from your mind.  Just
remember one thing ATM.  Always have to buy ATM.
Got entry even it is 4th
minute.  And you are saying no no, I did
not get entry.  If you don't get entry then
brother, leave the stock market.  Get a job for ₹15 to ₹20,000.  Don't
think too much.  Isn't it?
Is it clear?  Look at this and where do we have to edge,
do it around 9:30 9:25 9:25 9:30
27 28 29 30 Look at this, the perfect trade is
over, I say there will be a stop loss in this, so on that
stop loss day you will have only
three, not more than that,
I also said more, if I
sit to trade then it will be zero
sir, I am making a very big statement, I am
telling you
Rajesh sir, all the people, all the
traders that I meet, they all say
that you cannot do option trading in the long term.
You cannot do option buying.
But you are a market veteran.  You've been
in the markets for 26 years and you say
that if you want to trade, start with options.
So how is there so much difference?   If you want to
trade, I do not say that you should
start with options.  But
start trading options because there
is less investment.   There
is less risk, the money is good.  If you have even a little
understanding of technicalities, then it has been
my experience that if someone is
taking positional trade in options, then he is
doubling the capital in 5 days.
Doubling his capital in 5 days.  And if he is
doing intraday then he is taking 10 taka every day.
Now you think how big the amount is.
10%
Sir, if it is like this then everyone does the same,
everyone gets this but not everyone knows how to exit,
you tell me, you are happy with 10 taika
sir, if I get 5 taika in a day then
I will be very happy, okay,
let's buy an option
at ₹22, what will happen to 10 taika, it has become
10 taika,
what will happen to 2.2, will you exit at 2.2,
that is a bit tough [laughs]
this is the magic of the market, 10 taika
sounds very good but the
trader does not want to exit.  If he does
n't exit, how will he
make a profit?  Let us understand this very clearly
and clearly that we have
taken a trade of VDL.  Ok?  For which we
got the option for ₹2.  Now this is an example.   Do
n't take it otherwise.  Its lot size is
3000.
Now what happened to 10 taka of ₹2?   If
10 taka of ₹2
goes up by 20 paise and 20 paise, how much profit will he make
?   It will be
very little.  I have a lot size of ₹100, ₹200,
not ₹3000.   It became
₹600.
What was his investment of ₹600?
became ₹6000.  3 2 6 Now
on an investment of ₹6000, how much is ₹600 per month
?   The
market operates for 20 days a month.
12,000 for 20 days,
so what was the investment?  6,000
6,000
How much return are you getting?
How good does 12,000 sound?  Who will do it?
nobody.
that's the point.
So sir you told it so easily that anyone can do
this.
People do it.  Believe me,
when you enter the market and take a trade, the
market is not your enemy and you are
also not a fool, you
enter after observing and evaluating it properly, but
after entering, the demon sitting inside will go further and further, it will go
here,
due to this it forgets that brother, I need
10 rupees,
here I am getting 15, so should I book, it does
not make a loss and this person is doing
stupidity, if there are one or two, then we can
handle it, but 90% is there, how will we handle it,
then we have to give a statement that 90% people are making a
loss.  Then we have to give a statement
that brother, option trading is risky.
Not there.  And Rishabh, let me tell you something interesting.  The
returns are same in both trading and investment.
And no one will tell you this except me.
How sir?
Let's move from one example to a smaller example to a
larger example.
We get a message on WhatsApp that if
you had invested ₹100 in Wipro, it would have been worth
₹700 crore today.  Isn't it?  How much fun it is to
listen to it.  If we had not bought Bullet in 1986
and had bought Eicher Motors stock,
we would have had ₹ crore today.  We could have had
Rolls.  It comes
from inside WhatsApp, right?
Ok?  That means
you took shares worth the price of the bike.  Now tell me,
when you invested ₹10,000 in the market, did
you dream that you would earn ₹700 crore
?
No.
So how much will you exit him for?   Will
you double it by 10% or 15%?
Yes, you will double it.  If you triple it
more than that then you are going to stop, otherwise
what is the meaning of this message, it is of
no use to us, it is of
no use to anyone, you want bullets,
you do not want shares and after
reading all this on WhatsApp, you
bought shares worth ₹1 lakh instead of bullets.
Ok?
Ok?  And then probably the price of the Bullet will be Rs
30400.  If we talk about the present, it is ₹5 lakh,
so you bought shares for ₹00, till
when will you stop, you will
sell them for 60000, 90000 brother, this is the truth,
this is the truth, no one stops till 3 crores.
No one even dreams of it.  He
thinks that it is good that now I will buy a higher model
Bullet.
We are the reality.  Now let us
talk about investment.  Simply
you invested ₹ lakh in the market.   The
money doubled in 5 years.  How would you feel
?
I feel I have made the right investment.   Will you
like it or not?   Would love to.
Because it is a bank, it is doubling the money in 10 years.
And your money doubles
in 5 years.  You deposited ₹ lakh.  You doubled that money
in three years.  Your
investment will be
very good.   It will be
very nice.  And you deposited ₹ lakh.
Your money doubled in 2 years.
Then what a great thing.   It's all
messed up, right?
Yes.  Now let us calculate this.  Did you
enjoy it or not?  I had fun in 5 years.  It became
more fun in 3 years.  It became awesome and fun in two years.
What could be better than that?  Isn't it?  That means ₹
lakh doubles in 2 years.  This means
you earned ₹ lakh on top of ₹ lakh in 2 years.
And what were your returns for one year
?  That means
you earned 50% i.e. ₹1 lakh.
Ok?  Now you calculate ₹1 lakh.   The
market is running for 240 days.  Ok?
What happened to 1 month?  This is 10 lakhs.   Do
n't calculate it for 1 month.
How much is 12 in 1 month?
Divide Rs 10 lakh by 12 months at 12%.
Rishabh, will you get your answer?   It will be
around 80.   It will
come around Rs 80,000.  And the market runs for these 20 days in a
month.
What will be the answer if we divide this ₹8,000 by 20
?
30 3000 approx.
3000 Now do you
need to invest ₹20 lakh to earn ₹3,000?
No.
How much will you earn this ₹3000?   Will
you earn ₹00 in 3000?   In the
first example you gave,
less was required.
Still, we will earn ₹3000 in ₹1 lakh.
We will
earn ₹20 lakh in 2 years.
But sir I am a retail trader.  I
meet a lot of traders.  The concept you just
told is not so easy in
practical.  If I am
not there then
sir how do I do that, I mean if I have to
learn any setup, I have to learn something that this is the
method, I should follow it from here, I have to
start from A and I have to go till Z, then
how do I go, yes I will have to learn the setup,
now you see what mistake the trader is making here, you know
whenever I
sit to teach someone, I ask him
that I have been in the market for 26 years,
yes I am
earning a good amount of money, how long have you been there, then
some trader says that I have been here for six months.  It's
ok.  It has been for 6 months.  Someone says
that I have been here for 2 years.  Now someone told
me that I have been here for 8 years.  Someone said
I have been here for 12 years.  I have been in the market for 12 years now.  I've been
in the market for 8 years and I've been
in the market for 6 years.  Would
n't that guy have learnt to earn Rs 3000 a day in all these years?   I
think he must have learned to learn.
He must not have learnt how to earn ₹3000 a day.  Must have
learnt.
You talk about yourself, if you are in a field for
12 years,
what will you gain?  You will gain this much, right?
Earn 3000.  Let me tell you that I did not
learn it.  Ok.  That's why he came to me.
Now after I teach him, will that trader
follow me?
No.  This is not possible.   Isn't it
?  This is also the magic of this market.  He will
pay the fees, learn and will not trust.
He will keep
moving from here to there and from there to here.  And this thing that keeps roaming around is
the reason why he is not earning ₹ lakh in 2 years.
Otherwise there is no reason.
And if we talk about setup, we have just
taught a setup to everyone when we went live.
Right sir.
What do you think?  How many people would have followed him
?
Sir, the way the comments came, I thought
many people would do it, but no one
tried it later and told me whether they did it or
not.
[laughs]
And only four people told me personally
that sir we did it and we
made awesome money.  The message from those four people
came only for three days.  Did not come on the fourth day.  So
this means that they are following
it or now they are looking for something new to
buy.  Isn't it?  Let's find something new.
So it is very easy to earn money in this stock market.
You do
n't need a lot of money for that.  It
is also very easy to create wealth.  You don't need a lot of money for that either.
If I start now,
I am young.  There are a lot of people like me
who have just entered the market in a year, two years, three years, four
years.  And they have to do
option buying.  They have this much
clarity because they are incurring losses.   If you are doing it then you are incurring loss.   Yes.
So sir, you have 26 years of experience,
so will there be one setup that you would say that
yes, you start from here and
yes, look, here I want to tell you a setup
which has been my experience and
which I share with everyone, you do this,
sit in the market at 9:15 and get
out of the market at 9:30. Now the first question
I want to ask you is whether
you would like to get out of the market at 9:30,
sir, people say sit after 10:00, you are
saying get out at 9:30,
this is the difference.
That's the difference.  You tell me when will the money be made?   It will be made
when there is movement in the market or when the
market has come to a standstill.   There will be
movement of course.
Second thing, when will the money be made?  It will be done only when you have to
use your brain and the setup is already done there.
Sir, mostly our setup is like this, is
n't it?  To get your head around, here are
50 scripts out of the Nifty 50.
And if we talk about F Endo, there are
200 scripts for future options.  So which
script would you like to brainstorm?
Script selection after 10:00 pm is
hard after 10:00 pm, isn't it?  And
most of the traders today do
options trading in Nifty, Bank Nifty and Sussex.  I
say get in stock.  There is Nifty, Bank
Nifty and Sussex.
But the money that the stock will make will
not be made by this.
Ok.
Good money is made.   Is there
any reason behind this?
Yes.  Yes, the reason for this is that
your capital expenditure in this is moderate.  It doesn't seem less.
Like if you want to work in Nifty,
you can work even for Rs 10,000.  The
lot size is 65 and ₹10,000 becomes enough.   If
you want to work in stocks, then you
need a minimum capital of Rs 70,000 to take good trades.  So it's
okay.  We put in the money.
Look, the trader
invests money in two ways.  One will deposit ₹10,000 and will make it zero.  The
other one will come with ₹1,000 and make it zero.
The third one will come with ₹1,000 and will make it zero.  By doing
this he does good worth one and a half lakh rupees.   So that's
great.  I am telling you that brother, you are a
trader, right?  Don't put ₹10,000 here.  Let me
tell you a very easy way.  Instead of wasting that ₹10,000
here, it would be better if you give it to your wife.
Tell your wife to spend these 10,000 rupees otherwise
I will spend it here.   If your
wife spends that ₹10,000, you will get one benefit
that your photo will be put up in the temple in the house.
She must have told me every day
that my husband is very nice.  Don't
fly here.  If you want to deposit a
good amount here, then bring an amount of Rs 40, 50,000, 70,000.
And let me tell you a setup that the
market starts 15 minutes earlier, in that too at 9:15.
Your trade will be done here at
9:15
and 40 seconds or your entry will come at 9:16.  By
9:30 you will have the money
that we just discussed.
From Rs 2000 to Rs 8000 and we do this every day.  It is
not that I am sitting in front of you and talking
big things.   I do this
every day and
many traders who have learned from me know this and even among them
many traders still cannot apply it.
But apart from this, I have
many such traders.  Now I am
saying many, many
because I do not have a single figure for it.
Otherwise I can also say that brother, 10
traders are doing it, 20 traders are not doing it.  It's not like that.
Now what needs to be done in this
?  You have to take the trade and
say goodnight at 9:30.  If you learn this much, can
I show you some setups here
?
Sir, I would definitely like it if we
saw it today because the market just
moved to 9:30 a while ago.
Yes, he left.  I start from where it is not ready.
Yes it is made.  Let me tell you a script today.
As we were talking,
we will sit at 9:15 and take profit and
exit at 9:30.  But saying good night
is very important.  Can we do this?
If
good night.
If the setup is good then
no matter how the setup is, can we say
good night after getting profit
?
Then this thought will come to our mind that it is a
very good day for me.  Let me take another trade also.   I have a
better day.  Let me take the third trade also.
I want to tell you a setup.
I want to tell you a script.
Where we are using this
that brother, you will say good night at 9:30.
Ok?  So here is a script
Power India.  Okay, it is already installed here,
sorry sir,
but where did this Power India come from?
Yes, I will also tell you that
we have put up this script of Power India, where did Power India
come from?  Good question.  Here we come to
NSC India.
Ok?  Here we are on NSC India.
NSC India is
here.  Ok?  Look, you understand
this.  I am telling you something very good.   Let it
load.   It's
loaded.  Went to market data.  Where did you go?
This went into market data and gainers and losers.
Ok.
Ok?  When we go into this gainer loser,
our surface opens like this.
Instead of Nifty 50, we will select
Security in F&.
Ok?  And
I love selling.  So here
we come to the loser.  So at 9:30 this
thing called Power India was
running here.  Where?
Who was in place of RVNL?  Power India.
Ok.  So I selected this one.
Power India.
So I can select any stock from here sir.
After 9:15 pm, grab the first script that
comes your way.  Ok.
Well, we didn't catch Conker.
Its
okay.  Conker was not caught
because it is a slow item.  It runs smoothly.   She
gives the money and goes away.  I will tell you this also.  If we
open this now, we will get Conker also.
[nasal sound]
But I selected Power India.
Correct?  Now here I come to the chart.
Pow India.  This has become the first candle.  Now
understand here how to trade?
Where did it open?  Look, here comes the data.
All the data comes here.  It opened at Rs
35435.  High was made at 35500 and low was made at
34635.  Ok?  But we have nothing to do with this.
When the
market opened at 9:15, we had to
wait there for 30 seconds.  This is fixed.
No bravery should be shown before 30 seconds.
So it opened and then made a high
of 35,500.  Well then.  We are waiting for
30 seconds.  What would happen after that?  And as soon as
it breaks the open price again.
Ok?
Opened at 35,435.  Hit a high of 35,500.
Now 35,400 35 is broken on the downside.  As the
lower arm broke, it confirmed
that it would not go up anymore.  Ok.   Do you
know who is trading?  Who is doing it
sir?  We are not traders like you at all.
This market is in the hands of two people.
FIIs and DIIs.
Ok.  And what is the strength of FIIs and DIIs
?  Name one basic strength.
Sir, he comes with crores.   That
means a lot of money.  Now tell me one thing.
Those who have a lot of money will lose?
No.
Ok.  Well, secondly, what basic strength does it have
?
The one who has a lot of power and money
also has a lot of power.
Right?
So who has the power?
With money.
With the money and the money is with FIIs.   There are
two people here to shake up this market.
FII DII.  First of all
clear this concept.  FII
whose job is to move the market.
DII whose job is to keep the market stable.
Right?
Both do their work.  You will see that at
3:30 some figures come out.  FIIs
sold, DIIs bought.
Right?
And you can backtest it throughout your life.  It will
always be like this.   If
FII sells,
DII will buy and if FII buys,
DII will
sell.
Will sell.  There are simple rules.   have
a child.  He has a mother and a father.
What will the father say if the mother slaps him
?   Nothing
happened.  OK boss.
Hey son, it's okay.  Come, let me give you a lollipop.
Hey, it's okay.  Why did you have fun
?  And if the father hits her, what will the mother
say?
Beans.
Beans.  You know that Papa goes to work and
comes back tired.  Why does it bother
?  It is like that.  Ambulatory.  Keep the second thing in mind.
Who is this?   The
same mother.  FII is the child, DII
is the parent, when FII attacks, DI will
take care of it, Haluhu Halu Halu, don't fool around son,
both of you have a lot of money, so these are their basic
rules, it is already fine, but now
we have to understand one more thing here Rishabh,
whether the thing which FII is selling is also being
bought by DII,
no not at all
because they are not telling what they have
sold
and they are also not telling what they have
bought, the
concept is so clear,
sir,
so who is doing this trade,
we are not FIIDI, okay,
fine, see what is its volume,
I will tell you another example,
what is the volume in this, ah,
now we will have to apply the volume, we will have to
apply it, okay, you check it,
sir,
apply the volume once.
Yes, I will put it on.
This is a volume figure.  How much volume is there in it
?
Look at this
16000,
we
are 16 of 16, right?  Simple.   This
means that it has
sold 16,000 shares.  Hmm.
Now if you multiply 16,000 shares with its closing price
then 34,885 is
enough sir.  So now you will have to use the calculator.   Isn't it
?  Now you tell me who has so much money
?
Not near retail.  FISI
Simple, right?  That means I am not trading here.
You are not doing it.  Even that normal
trader who has ₹70,000 is not doing it.
So who are we trading on?  On the
thinking of these people.
You tell me what will you do if there is a goon in your area
?  Will you fight with him or be
friends with him?
Of course we will not fight.  I will only do friendship.   Isn't it
?  That brother, let my life go peacefully
, let your life also go peacefully.   There is a
very rich person in your office
who is working with you apart from the manager.
What would you like?  Friendship,
enmity,
friendship
or itch?
friendship.   Isn't it
?  There is money.  He will use it with you too.
What is the meaning of this?  That one should make friends with rich people.
Who is rich here?
FI.
What has he done?   Has been
sold.   Has
sold.  Isn't it?
So now that he has sold, he will come to buy,
which means this stock will go down further.  This is my brain, is
n't it?  You have been in the market for 2 years, 5 years
, 12 years.  These are
simple rules that the person who has sold will
come to buy
i.e. he will give the signal.  Now our concept
here is that whatever we talked about in the first minute on the buy
side, we did it only so that
you understand this strategy.  It's
very nice.  So now when it
crosses the open price, it will
not come up on the lower side.  Now you have to do options buying.
Sir,
now tell me one thing.  Sir, one more thing, you
said that we have to see the market at 9:15 30 seconds.
Ok?
Yes, I have already seen it.  Yes, we
will trade then for the
sake of trade.  So if we use a 30 second candle here, then
we will not get a 30 second candle, right?  You
get a minimum of 1 minute.
So we see in seconds.  Meaning,
yes, our time keeps passing here.
Look, this time is passing.  So we
understand it.
So anyway, when you practice,
you understand that yes, 30
seconds are over.  It's been 40 seconds.  Come on, you're scared.
1 minute is understandable, right?
Okay, we can see for 1 minute.
Yes.  Isn't it?
Ok.   Within
1 minute it becomes clear that the candle is
complete.
Ok.
Ok.  So we will take entry
at 50th second, at
40th second the candles are about to end.
We are
ok.  So now tell me one thing.  Here
I am telling this data of the last candle because it is
9:30 now and now this data has
no value at all.  So
according to the rule, this is history data.  Right?  Ok
?  Otherwise I would not have even told this.  Correct?
So now tell me as a trader
what do you think here?  Will
the market go up or down?  Will this stock go up
or down?  Look, the market is going up.
Sir, I see that there is a gap there, so the
gap can also be filled.   The
gap can be filled.  That means it can reverse from here.
When will it happen?
When buying pressure comes.   Will
you buy or sell here?
If the data I see is right,
I will sell.
Or the other way is that you will not do anything.
Yes, it is, is
n't it?
But at least you won't be buying.
That's it, isn't it?
Right.
Two things will happen.  You either make a sale or you do
nothing.  So here I
want to assure you one thing that if the first
candle is red then most of the time it
remains red for 15 minutes.
Now you have it.  It is in your hands.  It is
in your mind whether you should take action or
watch it.  Like this, piece by piece.
Correct?  So we will take action here
that we will sell it.
Ok?
Now when you sell it in equity,
sir, the script is worth ₹34,000.  I have ₹70,000.  You will be able to
sell two shares.
Right?
Ok?  And you will sell it in MIS.
You will sell it only in MIS because there is
no delivery.  So if you sell in MIS,
you can sell 50 shares instead of two.
You won't be able to sell more than that.
But I say that if
we buy put here then
it will be a much better option,
we will get stop loss as well and we will earn even a single penny, there is
no hassle of thinking, secondly
today our expiry is
at 26, yes
right
this is the expiry which we are telling, what is the close,
our close was 348585,
Rishabh ji you know the basics of options,
ITM ATM OTM, right,
here I want to tell you one thing that
whenever you do options trading, you should
remove ITM ATM OTM from your mind,
just remember one thing, you should
always buy ATM ATM, if you do
not have money then do not buy but do not
go near OTM.
Its Reese
Reese this is there's a
fire here.
So how far will the heat reach?  There is a fire here.
You have to cook khichdi.  Where
should the pots be kept?
Near the fire.
Here or here?
Off course near the fire.
Which one will cook faster?  The one here or the one
below here, will it get cooked or
not, it will not get cooked,
it will not get hot, it will not get cooked, it will not get hot
and what do we want, it should get cooked, it should get cooked, that's all,
we don't have to think about anything else, the
reason why most of the traders are making losses is that they are going to
OTM
and why are they going to OTM?   It
is cheap
because it is cheap
and whatever is cheap in the market is not good.
And what is expensive is also not good.
I am also saying this statement to you.  What
is cheap is not good but what
is expensive is also not good.  But whatever is
available on time at perfect facility, whether it is
cheap or expensive, is good.   It is the
best.  So you tell me that its close
is 34885.
Which putt would you like to take?
Which one will come nearest to the spot?
Which one will come nearest?
According to 34885,
34900 will not be there in this, so can we
take 35000 and 35500,
okay, so we can take a put of 35000 here, we can take it
and we can also take a put of 35500,
we can see both of them once, now see here, whatever he did, it went up, it went down,
this trade got closed,
after this here I want to say that this
thing will remain red for 15 minutes.
Ok.
Ok?  So you just have to hit enter.
Sit comfortably.  There is no problem at all.
Correct.  Now can I convert this in 15 minutes
?
Ok.
Ok.  Now look at this.  This is the first candle of the day.  Are you
watching?   Yes
sir.   The
red is completely ready.  If you can come at 9:30 and
say good night, I will show you some magic.
Ok sir.  Absolutely.
Ok.  So we come here and look at the call of 35500, the
put
opened here, went down and this closed.
Correct?  Now let me convert this also in 1 minute.
1 minute we are on the 26th.
9:15
Next.
Here's 16 opened went down.  Now here it
opened and closed.  You entered and
now what do you have to do?  Have to wait for 15 minutes.  If it is
open then we will come here again.
Where did you get these candles?   I
got these candles approximately at 845
or 825.  You saw that in the 1 minute
trade
and where did this one go
high, see what has happened, the
high has reached 1194
and where did this other one go, that is
1491 930, that means this is a candle of 945.  You
[nasal voice] tell me one thing,
what is the closure of this now?
Its closed sir
okay.  What is lot size?   It
's 25, right?  A quantity of 25 will be 100 times the difference.
How much will it be?   I am simply
saying 100% difference.  Its
close has come from ₹842 to ₹92.   You will get
₹2500.  It has
made a high of 1190 on us after you took it.
Right?
That means how many points did it go up?  300 points.
300 points
in approximately how many minutes?  In 15 minutes.
What will be 25 * 3?
7500 Would
n't you like to book?
Absolutely sir.   You
see 5,000 in front of you.  Would
n't you like to book?
Absolutely.
So this magic happens every day.   It's been happening for years.
Sir, we can go on a random date like this.
How can I get a date on a random date?   At
any
given time, the
data we have on options is for one
month only.
Hum
but I can show you the stock.
You can choose any date.  One week ago,
two weeks ago, three months ago, one
year ago.  Sir, let's do this, Sir, let's
see the budget date.   Let's
see the budget date.  Look at Nifty
or any stock,
sir, I can look at both.   That's
ok.  So first this stock is open.   Let's just
look at this.  It may have been
red or green, sir.
Whatever it is, we have to see the first candle.
What was the date?
A first of a kind.
First of all, Fab.
Yes.
Oh wow.
What is this?  Did you
see
where the bean was opened?   It did
open.
18990 hit the high of 19,000
and after that
close 18630,
that is, which candle was formed instead of this?
Red, you can say good night.   Can
speak.
You can tell me any date.  Be it an event, budget,
election, tariff, rocket launch,
Russia's
date, whatever it may be, we are sitting here, something will still happen, the
first effect must have been felt here.
I want to assure you of one thing,
what I have seen in these 26 years and what
[nasal sound] I have understood
and those people here do not want to tell this to the
retail traders because their
business will be ruined.  Otherwise, the thing I
want to tell you is that nothing happens suddenly in the market.
Neither gap down happens suddenly nor gap up
happens suddenly.   Do
you understand?  What am I saying?  You
tell me how much money does FII have?
Crores of money.
Can you give an example?
1000 crore 2000 rupees per person, take that much money.  Elon
Musk How much money does he have?
Sir is the richest man in the world.
These people can buy and sell this Elon Musk 100 times
at a time.  He has so much money.
how often?
100 times.
Now you understand how much money he has.
Now you tell me one thing.  Okay, even if
we get caught 20 times and not 100 times, it still means a
lot of money.
How much power will a person who has so much money have?   The
more power there will be.  Sir,
if Elon Musk can
make Trump the king of America, then
these people
cannot make anyone else.   You
can make everyone, right?  Can you make it dance on your fingers
or not?  And this is the reality, is
n't it?  Who made Trump this time?
By Elon Musk.
These people can buy and sell it.
He has so much money.
So nothing happens suddenly here.
His eyes are everywhere.
What are you and I looking at?  CNBC
Yes.  What will you see above that?  What does a retail
trader have to look up to on CNBC
?
And if someone is watching the highest version of it,
they are watching Boomberg.
What does he have on top of that?
No.
So who will get the news first?
Near the Boomberg one.
Who will she come to after that?
CNBC.
And even before this, all the activities take place here.
Then there's a flash on Boomberg,
followed by a flash on CNBC.  So
what is the retail trader looking at?   The one who is
coming last.
Hey, I threw a bomb.  Bomb thrown.  Hey, he
threw a bomb.  They know when you slept at night
and other such things.  Gift Nifty keeps on
going, right?  The gap went
down here.  Have you ever seen the gift Nifty gap, if the
gap continues while going down then
it continues.
Our Nifty is gapping down.   The
gift is not being given after looking at Nifty.  Have you
ever seen a gap down or
gap up?
So the
market is closing here.   The
market is not closing at the international level.
Here the commodities market is gapping up
and down every day.  Whereas
in comics XU USD
trades
every time.  There is only a half-hour
window for closing.   Isn't it
?  And Forex is never
closed except on Saturday and Sunday, and even
better than that, Crypto is sometimes
open on Saturday and Sunday and
sometimes not open, so
these people have minute details about every
stock,
every country, every state and every
leader, what he is thinking and what he is going to do.
Those people will
not incur any loss.
So why would we do it?
We will trade with them.
We will stay with them, right?  Brother, he thought he had to go
down.  Let go.  We will also bring him down.
Ok.  This is just an example.
Sir, you have just named so many assets,
so will my strategy
work on all of them?   It will
work on everyone.  Yes, it will work on everyone.
Gold Silver Crude will
work on Indian market.
You will not be able to stay awake in the international market.  The
ex-service market starts at 4:30 pm.
Where will you wake up?  Yes.  But what
I am telling you here is a rough page.
You have to understand this very well, so
in this course I have explained all the
things very well at the macro level
and also at the micro level.
So [nasal sound] when you
subscribe to that, you'll get access to cool stuff.  Even
if you do not do this and
just watch it, you are still making very good
profits.
But if you do it,
you have an axe which is not sharpened
and you are cutting the tree with it and
you have an axe which is sharpened
and you are cutting the tree with it, which one will
cut the tree quickly, the one which has a sharp edge, if it has a sharp edge then take the one with a
sharp edge, the tree will definitely be cut,
when I am saying this then I
am giving my 100% but if the
tree has to be cut in the right way, in the right manner, then
what is required in the axe?   If you
want to stream then you must subscribe to it.
You will find good things there.
You will understand.  You will get good things.  Let me
give you another example,
we can see someone else on this date.
Ok?  Look at the eagle fin like this.
I have taken this randomly.  Now let's go
back to that date in our minds.   Let's go
sir.   It is on the
same day,
where is Go, this is it,
yes sir,
9:15,
this is yes, okay sir,
yes see, it has not given entry at all,
no, it has not given entry sir,
now why has it not given entry, you are looking at the first candle
of 1530, it has opened in the middle of it, so it has
not given entry,
such things and we have
covered all such things there,
okay,
see, this was also the thing to select this stock.
And I will select one stock and tell
you.  Ok?   Beans.
And we go on a date.  Where is Go February 1st
?  This is it.
Went up, came down and red.  So look like this, it is
not open in the middle.  Isn't it?  It is broken open.
Gave some clarity.  So this is clarity
for you who want to understand it very well.
And this second day, 2nd February, the
same thing
opened, the same
third day the gap up opened, it came in one go, is
n't it a good thing.  This January 29th
we can go back even further.  Look
what happened on January 28th?  Green
What is it made of?  Green.
Green.  What is it made of?  Green.
Green.  So you earn money by buying and
also by selling, sit and buy calls,
sit and buy puts.
Learn to say goodnight at 9:30.
Ok.  And sir, this will work in Nifty also.
Nifty moves very little.
Ok.  So it means it
works but it works very little.   Let
us see an example, sir.   Yes
absolutely.
Look what was made?
Became green.
Green is green, green is green, green is
green, red is red.
Sir, let us also check with today's options.   Yes
absolutely.  Why not?  Let us also look at today's options.
This brother was at 9:15.  Today
is the date.  NFT will go to 50 options.  Which
one is it?  See the call for 24,000.
Let's see sir.  Today
[nasal sound] is
fine.  Where did it open?  It went down to 81 at 95
and hit a high of 124.  We
can see this even in 1 minute.  A great
trade is made.  Expiry date is the next day.   That
means he will move up and down a little.  Ok?
So this is the 26th and this is the 25th.
25 25 25
and this is 25 1 o'clock, it will keep
coming like this sir, no no it is done, here it is,
see
where it opened, it
opened sir, high at 95
95,
low at 124
81,
high at 124, same Nifty also became
green, it hit a low, then it ended after making a green candle,
now you see here Nifty has
made a green candle and it has made a doji.
What is the reason for this?  Because now it is
nearing expiry.   He
is very stingy.
Ok?  So he has to duck and
also come up.  That means he has to both reduce and
increase the price.  So in this way you will get to
see such candles a week before the expiry.  But your entry
will be perfect and your profit will also be perfect.
You just answer me one simple question
that if something is bought at 95 then it goes up
to 124.  Will you book it or not
?   I will do it
sir.  30% is almost done.
Now let me tell you a truth that the
average traders of Nifty
book even at 10 points.
And those who are left also book for 20 points, thinking that they
got 20 points and
booked profit.
This is nifty simple logic.  And the banks which are
operating in Nifty, they book at 25 points to
60 points.  Averagely.   There are only a few
traders who stand for 100 points and
200 points.  Otherwise
it is routine.  Bean thing.  People who are
working in Sussex book at 60 points to 80 points.  If
this comes on average then it is
fine.  So here even if the one which is priced at Rs 95 goes for Rs 105,
you will still book it.
Right?
Ok?  And even if it goes to 115, you will still book it.  So what I
mean to say is that the success ratio here is
very good.  Look at this.
Correct?  Now this is rad.  What would this mean for a put
?  It must have been green.  Correct.  Now there's
green here.  This is also green.  Open and low
beans.  Let us see which data we have taken?
Option C D is taken.
Right?   Isn't it
?  Open and low same 60 60 how far did it go
in the top?   I
went upstairs sir.   It's
100,
right?  Now, even after being scared, you will get the one which is worth ₹60 for ₹
65, 70 or 80, right?  That
open and low bean is open.  That means he is
going like this, like this.
Where will you buy it?   You will definitely buy it for
68 70 70.  Come and wait.
How far did it go?  up to 100.  Book with ease.
And where did he give the close?  At 73.   I could have
bought it even at Rs 70.
So book it at 73 and leave brother.  I have to
say good night to you at 9:30.  It's your fault.
You didn't book upstairs.
Ok?  And if he has not booked above then even when the price keeps
falling below ₹100, he will book it.
Right?
End.  This is beauty.
And sir, is there any stop loss etc. in this
?   There is a
stop loss.  That's why we keep stop loss.   There will be a
stop loss.  Have to exit at stop loss.
In this,
how many days will the stop loss be in 20 days as mentioned?   What do
you think?
Sir, if I see 50% in 20 days, then I
say that there will be a stop loss in it for 10 days, so on the
day of stop loss,
you will have only three, ok, there will
not be more than that, I also
said more, if I sit to trade, then it will be
zero,
sir, I am making a very big statement, so
I am telling you, now I do
not want to say anything in the air, I am
telling you whatever is visible because
this is how trades are made because every time
our script selection is different.
So every time we have new data.
We have less chance of that error.
Yes,
today we have seen Power India and the second one
we saw was Wari.  Okay yes, we have seen it very carefully
sir.   Let's see.  Let's see the
story.  Look
how cool it was.
Oh what's the matter.
Say.
Sir, I will sit for a month after doing this trade.   You
think you can sit for a month.
[laughter]
What do you see?  Isn't it?  Awesome
Absolutely sir.
Now you have to take the trade after 1 minute or after 30 seconds.
This was our first trade of
Wari.
Sir, let's see in 1 minute.   Yes
absolutely.
Oh what's the matter.   It is like this.
Even got entry.  It is the fourth
minute and you are saying no no I did
not get entry.  If you don't get entry then
brother, leave the stock market.
15. Get a job for ₹2000.  Don't think too much.   Isn't it
?  Is it clear?  Look at this.  And where do we have to
exit?  So do 9:30 around 9:25.
9:25 9:30 27 28 29 30 Look at this.
Perfect trade over.  Brother, okay let us
see its options,
sir,
which one is it, let us
see the option of 3000 3000 3000, okay it has come,
sir, here it is,
okay,
3000 option, ah, here it is, no, let us
not see the one of 3000, you see in 3000, the
depth is not
equal, there is no liquidity, there is no liquidity,
three three three three three three, write in 3000, let us
see the one of 3100 once.
Ok sir.
One minute.  Yes, it
is here sir.  It is here.
Where did you come from?  Will you come in a minute?
Yes, here it is.   Isn't it
here?
Ok.  Here it is.  Look where did you get entry on 26
?  Opening is 53.  The
low is 53295.  That means open and low is almost the same.  It's the same
here.   There
is a difference of 5 paise.  Where will your entry
be made?  So its high is 56.  So 56
60 62 see its second candle has opened
at 65,
so let's say at 65 we got entry, buyer
seller would be standing there, there was no depth then, so where did this 65 one go, this one went at
100 929, now where did 91 91 go in this candle, the
exit has happened here, so
can you exit or not, okay
what is the lot size, lot
size
and you are getting full ₹40, okay if
you got ₹30 also then
my work is done, is
n't it,
and here we are talking about just one lot to one lot
and if I am doing multiple lots then
I have more options, of
course that is your wish, but I would
like to say that work on single lot here
brother
sir, everyone says that you should pick two-three lots and do the
trail.
Everyone has different thinking.  Please tell me one thing.
I want to tell you a psychology of money.
You can earn only as much as you can afford.
Right?
What is meant by status?  You tell me this.  You
ask questions.
As much as I can handle.
And how will you be able to handle it?
That is in your mind, isn't it?
Your mind is not made for that thing.
So you can't think beyond that.   You
cannot see more than that and if you
get more than that then your brain will
release chemicals from here.
Our subconscious mind
wants to calm us down and
keep us in our comfort zone.  And
I want to tell you everything else.
Whose salary is ₹1 lakh.
He came to know the next day that his salary was going to be
₹ lakh in the next month.  What will
happen to him?   Then he will
not be able to think anything.  I'll tell you
what will happen.  Within six months he will become poor
because his mind is not made for it.
Where is all his setup made?  1 lakh per   It was as if
he suddenly saw 3 lakhs.
He will fly away.
Drinking
and many other things
and more expenses.
How much will you get in your hand?  1 lakh.  Because
what is his status?   Worth
1 lakh.  What will have to be done for 3 lakhs?
What do I have to do, sir?   You will have to
make up your mind, sir.  It cannot be achieved just by thinking.
For that, the mind will have to be set up.   It
is hard
Sir, you have so much clarity and you have
done so much at this age, you have been
in the market for 26 years, you have so much clarity in options,
I have not seen people like this, I have not
generally seen traders who have
so much clarity about options, so
how did you achieve this much Sir, what has been
your journey, if I
talk about your journey then let me tell you that
in the year 2000 when I came to the market,
Harshad Mehta was finished and
Ketan Parik was also finished, his era was
finished
and SEBI wanted it, the
country also wanted that our stock
exchange should move in the right direction so that
we can improve our image at the international level.
When I entered in the year 2000,
Future had come into the market.
Ok.
Before that the hawala system was in operation.   There was a
lot size in futures and there were
no guidelines then that
we had to
trade like this.  There was no circuit limit.
I have seen ACC worth ₹800 being sold for 35 paise right in front of my eyes.
35 paise
35 paise ₹2 ₹10 is a
thing worth ₹800.  This is how ACC is working, I had to do it tough.
How much did it cost?  Came for ₹20.
People are happy, oh ₹20
and the one which is available for ₹8.
What should I do?  And then guidelines used to come that
brother, whatever price was below 10 taka,
whoever came, everyone's deal was cancelled,
so I have seen these days, it all started from here
[nasal sound]
future started here and
after future, after 6 months,
options started here, after 6 months or
a year, so I understand it from the base that
what are these futures and
options, that is why I have
very good clarity about options and you are
asking for clarity about the rest of the money, I was
25 years old,
who will give me money to enter the market,
of course I will get it from home,
father will give it
and we are five brothers, I am the
eldest, okay
why will father give, I have my own business,
sitting in business, whatever the stock market is
doing even today, in 2026, we have to
hide it.   I don't
tell anyone that I am doing stock market.
What will happen if I tell?   The
name will be ruined.  It is a gambling.  Do
n't give him money.
Goodwill is over.  And in our times, we couldn't even find a girl for
marriage.
What are you talking about?  [laughter]
As it turned out, in the stock market, the girl
's father would tell her to stay away.
So if you think about it,
clarity is important.  So when I
came into the market, I must have been like this
?
No
or Home was the same as
you.  He was like everyone else.  So many
traders are coming here, but even then
my mind was clear that the making is here only.   As of
today, it has happened that I am not
very big.
But I understand that the
market is moving as I am saying.
So tell me one thing, is the
market moving as I am saying?
No, I am telling you how the market will move.   That's why
I'm being right.
As the market is about to turn, I think the
technicals there are very good.
I have a very good grasp on the price.  So I hold on to it
that from here the market will move
upwards and from here the market will fall
downwards.
Because of this, my traders here
are very successful and I am also very successful.
Sir, if you have started then you must have incurred losses
also.  6 lakh
6 lakh
in two-six months
Sir, what was the value of 6 lakh at that time [laughs]
Sir,
yes and you think how much I must have suffered at
home, oh it was there at that time, the
rules were not so strict that if you don't have money then your
trade will not be done then
[nasal voice] so
sit in front and trade and the broker knows, yes
whose son is he, he is his son, don't hit him, it will happen like this,
we will recover the money from his father also, he doesn't have a name,
now we do
n't have a name, father had a name, he had
goodwill.   There was
goodwill but the broker keeps recognizing it.
Yes, he has a son.  Ok.  Papa
also comes to know.  Hey friend,
you have done so much, you took so much from me, 2
lakhs.  Who will fill this?
So when such days came, I lost Rs 6 lakh.
I sat at home.  Papa
said sit on business.  I say I do
something.  wait.   The
marriage had taken place.  The interesting thing is this.
Oh how are you sir?
Hey, that's the amazing thing, isn't it?  I got married first, I got
married in the month of February in the year 2000
and I entered the market in the month of June in the
year 2000.
Ok.  That means you first planned that
no, no trading, get
married first.
Because there will be no marriage later.  That was fixed.
Yes.
Because the matter gets resolved.  If there is a fire,
smoke will definitely
fly.  You can't hide that.
Now what?  Now if you want to take that girl then take her.
Who will take it?  Isn't it?  So, but it's okay.
I sat at home for two years and read many good
books.  Okay, it's happening.
And I understood that
if you want to survive here then you have to
control the price.  I
learned to catch the price very well and from 2003 to 2026,
and in between, Sir, there were many incidents,
before Covid came, there was a crisis in 2008,
everything came before my eyes, even I
want to tell you one thing, in 2007, there was a
lower circuit here in 8,
okay, and then we, RR Chaukhani, were the
main brokers, and let me tell you, many
brokers, we were sub-brokers under him,
but when this lower circuit happened, after that, all the
brokers who were there, they
reached the broker level and made so much money, now
what is the interesting thing, you know that at that time, only two
brokers were working in the market, when the
lower circuit happened, then one was RR Chaukhani
and the other was probably BALB Securities,
he is a broker from Delhi, apart from him, all the
brokers, all of them were
looting the wealth of their clients,
that is, they were selling it.  Margin Short For Now
why were these two staying in the market and
why was their margin liquidated?  Because he did
not have any client based work.
[nasal sound] They only hired
traders to trade.  That means he used to do his own
trading.  We used to
sit at the pro desk.  Our job was to make
you trade in profit sharing.  Ok
?  So we did and that day I
made my biggest profit in the lower circuit.  How much would have been
made?  What was the lower circuit in 2007
?
70 lakhs 70 lakhs
and the data which I am telling you would be present
in their books even today
with my name that yes brother, this guy was a broker
and he made this profit and
after that we stopped this profit selling work and said that you should do it
yourself.  Now
we have enough capital also.  It has become a great
thing.  And this company of mine,
we
established it by doing research and established it around
2009 [nasal sound] and
we are five brothers, as I told you, the
third brother was a CA, he became a Chartered
Accountant.  He himself suggested to me
that brother, you are earning.
Tell others also how you are earning.
Otherwise what is the benefit?  That means if
we have taken something from the society then return it to the society.
These are the rules here.  I said yes,
this is also true.  So when we started this in 2009,
we used to teach for free.
Come sit near me.  You have to make money.
Come sit and learn.  Learn, learn, learn.  For 2 years
we taught everyone for free.  But we
understood one thing.
No one values ​​free things.  No one values ​​it.
I am giving you such a good thing.
This thing is so good.   They do
n't understand at all.  Keep doing your own things.
Then we converted it into a tree.
No, work with mentorship.
Support him.  Give lifetime support and move ahead.
This was my journey.
And Sir, you mentioned that you
read books, so did the books help you?
Yes, you should read books.  I am telling everyone.
Read books.  Yes,
what's on your mind reading?  That is a different thing.  And
what my mind is is a different thing.  Isn't it?
But in a 500 page book, there are five pages
which are going to change your life.
That writer has given 20 years of his life to write that 500 page book.  So
you simply take his 20 years for yourself.
You will also get those five pages which will
change your life.
I did not read even one of that 500 page book.  I read 80 books, that's why,
yes, that's why there is this stock exchange there, there is
our
fashion street in front of it.  You must know it.
A book is also lying in front of him.
Many books like this on the road.
Right?   I used to go
there and bring it.  One book each.  First of all,
I read 80 books, many of which were
related to the stock market.  There were different authors
but one thing was common in all of them, I talk about each and every book
even today.
Pick up any book on stock market.  You wo
n't read 10 books, right?  The same thing might be written in that one book as is
written in the remaining 10 books.
Because I had read all the books.
So I read a book where it was written
that catch the price action.  Which book was it
?
In every book.
Well, here the invention
of candles was done by a Japanese trader.  Everyone knows that
he was a rice trader and this and that,
so I do not want to give details about that.
But the books he wrote were
in Japanese language and from there they were
converted into English.  Ok?
If you understand those books properly, you will
understand the market 100%.  I don't
want to decode that.
You do the decoding.  You don't need to learn anything else.
What more can I decode?
I have given 26 years to this market.   Do you
understand?  And that is a very good thing and
I learned all the other things by
reading all these books, life psychology
mindset
because when you want to become rich then you
need your own mind, the mind of the rich does not
work.
You cannot become rich with this mindset.   There
should be peace in the mind
and
courage to see the loss when it is happening.  There are
four types of traders.
Intraday, Swing, Positional and Investor.
Now there are two types of investors.  Short
term, long term.
Yes.
How much does everyone earn?
12%
will earn 15% of the beans.
But the intraday trader is making losses and the
positional trader is making profits.  The investor is also
earning.  And this is the truth
of the market.  Why is this happening?
Whereas I am saying that everyone's income is the same.
Everyone's profit is the same.
And I have just taken an example that
if you have invested ₹ lakh in the market and it is
doubling in 5 years, then how would you feel
?  You said it would be very nice.
How would you feel if it doubles in 3 years?  So
you said it looks very good and it will happen in 2 years, then
you will be able to earn
₹ 1 lakh by investing, but after that we
calculated, do we know
how much should we earn per day to earn ₹ 20 lakh in 2 years,
then your answer came only ₹ 3000, so this
intraday trader
cannot do this at all, but
that too with very less capital,
yes, with a capital of 70, now
calculate how much capital did you invest in this trade, you bought Vari
International at 60, what is the lot size,
175,
that means how much investment was made, 60 * 175, and if you
sell at ₹ 40 above, then it will be
175 * 40,
what will be the answer, we have
7500 of ours, that
we had calculated, take 7000, if you will earn
7000 on a capital of 15000, then
you will not like it.  The rate of return is
50%.
But do you think that trader will
take home Rs 7000?
No.  Will trade next.
Tambur: Yes, he will take only Rs 2000 home.
He will not close the trade.  First
time, second trade, third trade, fourth
trade.  Today 7000 came.  Let me kill you more.   Let me
kill you more.  And there will be traders
who will incur losses.   The
profit is 7000.  Hey, you won't take 7000.   Nothing.
I have Rs 2000, I will deposit it.
Those who don't say goodnight, those 7,000 will be
down in the next 15 minutes [laughter]
or at 3:30.
Yes.
Okay, tell me one thing.   The
salary of a person is ₹ lakh
₹0000.  And it is ₹00.  How many hours
will these three men work?   Same
time.
8 hours for ₹000 will also work for 8 hours.  Even the one earning ₹1
lakh will work for 8 hours.  And will the one with ₹ lakh do
more than 8 hours or
not?   Will
his stress level be high or not?   will be.   Isn't it
?   Will
he do it off the clock or not?   Will do.  It is definitely
going on in his mind.
No, where?  You will get a call from there that his
server line is down, just see, you are
sitting on the laptop, what are you paying 2 lakhs for, if you go
out then
no one is going to give you 2 lakhs, so you will do it
and if his salary is 3 lakhs then he will do that
too,
he will do it reluctantly, he has to do it
because he is at a higher level,
so
tell me one thing, now the one
whose salary is simple 1 lakh.
What was his daily income?
is 3000, right?  There are 25 days left for work and he is
ready to work 8 hours to earn ₹3500.   The
same guy is not ready to take ₹3500 if it comes in 15 minutes.
So what happened?  Isn't it a miracle?
Because he has got into the habit
of working as a labourer that if I work for 8 hours then I am
getting ₹300, then
how can I take the ₹3000 that you would have got in 15 minutes, that is his
status which you have given,
yes he is a labourer, he will not understand, for that a
mindset is needed,
even the rich are getting ₹3000, stop it, tell me one
thing, now
he got the next ₹5,000 in 15 minutes and he is
working for 8 hours now, then how will his remaining
7 hours go?   You will
go very well.   You will
go very well, energetic guy, you have
got money from here also.
Awesome [nasal sound]
how will he talk to everyone?
Being very happy.   Be
happy and energetic.
So should we take energy or not?
Absolutely.
So all I want to say here from this platform is that
friends, learn to close the trade.
If you are not learning how to close a trade, then no matter
how good a setup you get,
you will not be able to make money.
Skip the setup.  Even if the person who is creating this setup
sits next to you,
you will not be able to earn.  Sir,
I have had so
many conversations till now that I have enjoyed talking to you.
I have met a lot of people.  I have met a lot of traders.
But I have not seen so much conviction and that too
in options buying
with any trader.  And especially
those who have as much experience as you, have
as much knowledge as you say.
So I am very thankful that you are sitting with us today.
We are shooting for about an hour and a half.
And in the hour and a half you've
convinced me so much that I think I'm going to
start setting options tomorrow [laughs].
So thank you so much sir.  And I, our
audience, whoever is watching us,
whoever will watch us later, please do comment.   Did
you try this setup or
what issues did you face?  And what else
would you like to learn from Sir?  And yes, if you want to learn this setup
in detail and learn it very well.
Pin point how to enter
, when to exit.  And yes,
when we read the setup in the course, Sir
also used paid points in it.  So
that their entry and exit can be better.
You can learn that too in the course.  And even
we have taken examples of different assets to see
how the setup works in different assets.
And go check it out.
You will find the link in the on pin comment in the description.
And yes sir, what
we have learnt here today is from his 26 years of experience.
And I believe you would have liked it very much.
So do like this video.  Please
subscribe to our channel and we will
definitely meet you in the next video with Sir.
And
you can also tell us by commenting what is the next topic you want to learn.
So thank you so much sir.
Thank you sir.  Thank you very much.